Good afternoon.
So many of you probably
have seen or tried
to help a workplace adopt R.
So this is the typical case
I see.
Your company hired an R trainer
who went over a lot of
fancy things possible
in R with the team.
After the training, everyone
finds R very cool.
The tidyverse amazing.
R Markdown awesome.
Shiny fantastic.
But then after a few
days, most people
just went back to the go-to tools.
I'd rather not call it out,
but something that's not R.
Several years ago, my
company moved to R
and we face the same
situation. To help change
that, I initiated s work
automation project with R,
and now we have 20 plus
team members who consider
R the go-to tools, 60 plus
stakeholders who use
R product on a daily basis.
And this has saved over
12,000 hours and counting.
In the next 15
minutes, I'm going
to talk about key parts of
the project, lessons learned
and the structure
you could follow
if you'd like to implement it.
Now let's revisit the situation.
We want to move things to R but
why on their many movements?
Well, we all have learning
curve as beginners.
Some of us went
through it quicker.
More of us don't.
The other scenario I can think
of is that after the training,
we're not asked to
handle the right tasks.
Some of those tasks
might not even
be covered in the training.
They may look similar though.
Even if you were able
to avoid the first two,
you may still end up
in the last situation
where you have a
grand plan of what
to do with your
project using R,
but had to go back
to the old ways
because your deadline
is the same. Now,
unfortunately, before
realizing any of these,
we assume everything will
work after the training.
When it didn't, we
just thought we need
to work harder on the next one.
In fact, in one of those
follow up training I provided.
I even remade the Lion King song
into Can You Use the R Tonight,
summarizing the functions
we talked about, but it still
did not help.
Turns out what do we need is
to create a soft landing that
will start small and help
the team to build confidence.
Identify the task
for them and plan
the effort for the transition.
My soft landing idea then was
to build a work automation
project using R.
And next, I'm going
to talk about the six
key parts of the project.
And in the end, you
will see why that
was perfect for this situation.
So to build an
automation project first,
let's look into what's possible.
At that time, I was a
member of a data team,
and for most data
teams on this planet,
you cannot escape from reports.
So let's take a look
at a typical report.
If we can describe a step by
step, like traveling on a map.
You first
open your app, maybe SQL
database, data lake, all that.
Then you update your
parameter and run.
Then you wait.
Export the data,
clean the results,
analyze it, update the format,
draft an email and send.
But then if you look again, it
almost looks like all of these steps
can be divided into three
portions where we just
use different groups
of applications.
For some of those reports,
I would start with
Oracle, move on to Excel
and then end it with
Outlook. For other reports,
I would just use
other applications,
but regardless of the difference
of those applications,
we all seem to start
from getting the data,
then doing the data wrangling,
analysis, visualization,
and end it with communication.
So if you have a report
that have any parts that
fits any of those
three portions,
we can replace that
portion with R code
with the help of those R packages.
And the good thing is there are
so many of these R packages.
Now, this makes
sense for the reports
that would take some efforts.
But how about
the process where the pain point
was running the test itself
and sharing the result
on a daily basis?
How about the
stakeholder request
where we just require you to run
a SQL query and share the data?
Well, they still
fit in the scope
of this automation project.
We just need a little bit more
help. When defining automation,
there are three types.
So the first type
or the one perfect
for the reports that will still
need some human involvement.
And that would be perfect
to be done with R code.
The second type
are the ones that
are good for the process
that does not necessarily
need human input, but will need
to happen at a certain time
and would be best with R
plus RStudio Connect.
Lastly, also my favorite, a
combination of the previous two.
In this case,
the human input will
come from stakeholders
and they can kick off
whatever processes
that will get them the answer
with the help of Shiny.
Now if we look at these
definitions, none
of those are new,
but the current R
ecosystem was able to offer
a brand new interpretation.
So after knowing what can
be done in the project
and what the current R
ecosystem can help you with,
time to sell it to
decision makers.
And whenever you're
selling something,
you want to talk
about its benefits.
So what are the benefits here?
Reproducibility- the first
word to pop in my head.
Then, we may get
less human error
if we code everything correctly.
And if we were able to
achieve the first two,
we to be able to save some time.
So I got a few decision
makers in the room, presented
them my plan of automating
all the tasks identified
in step one, along
with the benefits here.
If I could replicate
the third interest
level using the gauge here.
So when I first talk
about reproducibility,
I gave them an example.
If I'm out of
office, someone else
can run all the tasks
that I'm handling.
Their interest level
wasn't very high, maybe
because it sounded very
similar to a travel insurance
where it is not
urgent at the moment.
You would only miss it
after things happen.
Then I moved on with less human error
but not additional interest
because maybe they are
thinking it is all theoretical
and code is written by human too.
Lastly, hours saved. More interest.
And then they even asked
me if I have any numbers,
but overall I did
not get the go ahead.
This is when I realize
I was so ready and so
prepared to sell this whole
thing to an R user, who
is more concerned about
the day to day workflow,
but not decision makers who
have no programming experience
and who is more concerned
about the return on investment
as well as business urgencies.
So I wait a few weeks
just after everybody
forgot about what I said,
and updated my strategy
and this is what I presented.
So I started with hours saved.
In fact, I told them, if
we go through with this,
we might be able to save
1,000 hours per year.
They're interested.
Then I moved on to less
human error
if we code everything correctly.
They're still intrigued.
Lastly, I sold
reproducibility like a free add
on travel insurance.
Who wouldn't love that?
Overall, we got the go ahead.
But then if you look
back, it is still
the same number
of benefits, just
in a slightly different order.
I guess sometimes it
makes sense for us
to start with the one
that does not require
too much context to understand.
And now you see why I name
the topic saving 1,000 hours
with RStudio, not bringing
reproducibility with RStudio.
If that was the talk theme, I
don't know if half of you
would show up or even
I would show up.
So after I get the
decision makers buy in, time
to get the things we need
to do the actual automation.
High level are two
things a document
of the current process
so that we know what needs to
be done, and information for us
to compare all the tasks
so that we know which
one to start with.
To get the
documentation, we will
need to understand
the current processes.
Well, you may say, wouldn't
that just need tools and steps?
Mostly, Yes.
But we will also need to
understand the business reasons
so that we can accommodate
any changes that may end up
making the process better.
We will also need to
understand the occurrence,
whether it happens
daily, weekly or ad hoc,
so that we can choose the
best platform or tool for it.
Lastly, we tend to
forget communication
as part of the automation,
and I would always
recommend saving a
few communication
examples in your document.
On top of that, we also want
to know the current efforts
in terms of the overall time for
each run before the automation
and what's the manual versus
processing time breakdown
and identifying the tough
items through this process.
Ideally, the automation
should always
work if we code things right.
But oftentimes it is not ideal,
which is why it
is critical for us
to know how often should we
update the process of document
so that we know when
it would be obsolete?
And oftentimes we are not always
the original report owner.
So we need to know when to stop
and call for additional help.
Now all of these will get
us a detailed document
of the requirements.
Of course, it's always
a great opportunity
to practice R markdown. But
other than the document itself,
we now know
the complexity of
potentially automating
this process, the impact as
well as the stability, which
would allow you to rank all
your tasks in a table that
looks like this.
So if you're wondering
which one to start,
you may not want to start
with task number one, where it
is complicated, has small impact,
and may require you to update
the code every other week.
You may want to consider
starting from automating task
number three, where it
is not overly complicated
will earn you some recognition
and there's less need for you
to update the code
and then maybe you
can move on to the harder ones.
After knowing what is needed
and identifying the task
to start with, time to
roll up the sleeves.
Now to do the actual automation,
there are so many
things to cover here.
In fact, I've been working
on an automation book trying
to cover all the
common scenarios using
two dozens of chapters.
So I would just be brief
here with my top three
recommendations.
My first recommendation is to
always start with components.
Let's just say if you have
a process that separately
involves SQL, Excel
and Outlook, you
want to code them one by one
because within the same team
and organization, the
same processes will
involve the similar
components where
you can just reuse the code.
My second recommendation is
that we should definitely
do plenty of tests to capture
all the scenarios possible.
Whether it be dependency
tests, user tests, dev tests,
unit tests.
We should do all
the applicable ones.
I know everybody
trusts their own code.
I do too.
But the reality has taught me
to trust the tests even more.
Lastly, be practical
and stay on target.
I know it feels great
to be able to build
all solutions within R.
But the thing is, not
everything needs to
be fully automated.
At the end of the day,
it is not about building
something cool with R,
but building something
impactful with R.
I've got lost in
that so many times.
So let me say this again.
It is not about building
something cool with R,
but building something
impactful with R.
Now after the coding
task, it is all done
and we can now just hand
off process and move on.
But there are still things we
need to look out for in order
to keep the project going.
Overall, there are
three deadly situations
that could affect your project.
The first situation is
that after you handed off
your automated processes,
someone ran the code.
But the result isn't
what's expected.
Because maybe because the
script wasn't handled properly,
like running on a new
machine or a new environment
without the proper setup.
Believe it or not,
after all these years,
it still happens to me.
So to avoid this situation,
what I would recommend
is to always have a handoff
document that discusses
the requirements of
the job, instructions on
running the process,
testing the process,
and what to do to maintain.
The second scenario
is that as you
build more and more
automated processes,
chances are multiple
processes may run into issues
at the same time,
and sometimes someone
will come up and then
need your help to fix it.
Sometimes multiple
people will show up,
which could look pressing.
So my tip for you is this.
Always discuss the failsafe
in your handoff document.
In most cases, a line like
this will do the trick.
This is almost like when the
autopilot stopped working.
You don't stop
flying or driving.
You switch back to manual. And
this often reduces the urgency
and give us the time to
properly fix the issue.
Lastly, everything went well.
You just got a new
feature request.
Should you directly jump in?
And my recommendation here.
Well, two recommendations.
The short term is that always
treat it like a brand new task.
So that you can start from
gathering requirements.
And then you can best
determine when to work on it.
And then the longer
term solution
here is that it is also
a perfect opportunity
for you to train your individual
team members to gradually take
on the task and
accumulate more R knowledge.
Now after you're comfortable
with dealing with those three
situations, we just need to
give it time for the project
to make progress.
And just like any of the other
projects, from time to time,
you want to share updates.
And to do that, I often
find it helpful to start
with the key stats.
For example, hours saved, which
is something you can easily
extract from the
requirement document
that you have built in the
previous steps, and the number
of process documents
now available because
of this project, as well
as all the training that
happened because
throughout this project,
whether it would be the official
one or the one-on-one sessions
that you had with
your team members.
On top of that, you
also want to share
any of the success stories,
learnings that happen along
the way and maybe give
kudos to your team member
that you collaborated with.
And lastly, you
don't want to forget
talking about the
hurdles where you
could use additional help on.
Other than that, you also want
to determine a good cadence
to share progress.
For me, it was once a
month, but you should always
set up your own and know that
you can share progress whenever
you have critical updates.
Now that wraps up the
key parts of the project.
If you would like to
start something similar
at your workplace, this is a
structure you could follow.
First, start from identifying
the task in your workplace,
then build your proposal
with the benefits
that would matter to your
decision makers and workplace.
After that, build a requirement
document with possibly with R
Markdown, identify the
right task to start with.
Then go by component.
Do plenty of tasks and stay on
target while at the same time,
try to stay away from the
three deadly situations.
And don't forget to share
progress from time to time.
Now I would like to ask
everyone to think back
about the original situation.
As we build more and
more automated processes,
we have completely moved on
from the original question
of why the R adoption rate isn't
what's expected after the R
training to now having most
team members owning several
of these R processes where
they were at least involved
in building the requirements,
testing the process
and execution.
Rather than expecting
everyone to connect
the R functionalities
to the business needs,
through the R training, we
connect the business needs
to the R functionalities
through this project
and we just happen to
save thousands of hours.
Now, if you're a decision
maker in this room,
this might be a good
project to make some impact
and accumulate some
R knowledge.
If you're a team member in
this room, bring this back
and start from
identifying the tasks.
If you're one of the two
team members in this room,
text your boss now and
say you have an idea.
Thank you.